la russie va pas y couper le robinet de
gaz après les sanctions économiques
prises par l'union européenne c'est une
possibilité en france en 2020 24 % du
gaz importé venait de russie la france
consommatrice de gaz russe ça dure
depuis plus de 45 ans milieu des années
70 le seul de l'urss est riche en
énergies fossiles dont du gaz ressource
inestimable l'union soviétique la
sibérie pourrait détenir dans son sol
jusqu'à un tiers des réserves de gaz
mondiales de quoi alimenter toute
l'europe de l'ouest le gaz russe arrive
en france dès 1976 après un accord passé
avec les soviétiques il est acheminé en
transport depuis les pays bas cette
année là le gaz russe importé en france
représentait 11 milliards de
kilowattheures mais la france importe
aussi de norvège d'algérie et surtout
des pays-bas en 1979 pour faire face à
une consommation toujours plus
importante la fonte construit son
premier gazoduc
sur le gazoduc se raccorde au réseau
russe qui passe par l'ukraine et
l'allemagne est ce que le gaz russe est
un bon gaz c'est un gaz équivalent au
gaz qui est actuellement distribué en
france c'est à dire c'est à gaza au
pouvoir calorifique et les importations
explosent en 1976 la france ont importé
11 milliards de kilowattheures quatre
ans plus tard en 1981 ce chiffre s'est
élevé à 38 milliards si bien qu'en 1990
l'urss devient le premier exportateur de
gaz en france nos sources
d'approvisionnement principales sont la
norvège
la russie l'algérie les pays-bas maison
2006 crise entre l'ukraine et la russie
sur le prix du gaz la russie réagi et
coupe le robinet à l'europe et les
conséquences se font vite sentir en
france
la france importé 134 milliards de
kilowattheures de gaz russe un record
puis en 2006 patatras le chiffre ton à
81 milliards mais pour françois loos
alors ministre délégué à l'industrie il
n'y a pas d'inquiétude à avoir nous
avons une politique d'approvisionnement
de sécurité énergétique qui est
importante nous avons des réserves
importantes dans ces conditions sur le
court terme je vois pas très bien ce qui
pourrait arriver aux consommateurs
français
depuis cette crise les importations de
gaz russe en france on était très
irrégulière en 2020 derniers chiffres
connus 90 milliards de kilowattheures
ont été importés aujourd'hui la russie
est toujours le deuxième exportateur de
gaz en france derrière la norvège si
nous sommes moins dépendants que nos
voisins européens
l'augmentation du prix du gaz inquiète
son cours a atteint les 345 euros un
record historique
[Musique]